what is up there reject nation we got
ourselves a book of boba fett chapter
one guys guys guys if you could leave a
like that would be great you're also
going to want to subscribe and click
that notification bell get notified when
our reaction for the next episode of
boba fett is up as per usual like every
reaction channel to have ever existed
full length watch along where you sync
up with the time code over at our
patreon page become a superject today
but check out all the content we got to
offer over there as well exclusively
lastly thank you to the boys over at
prepper for helping us edit down these
highlights i'm excited for this man
tomorrow morrison kicks so much pizzazz
in mandalorian season two let's see how
far back they go into the man's
backstory
he needs to remember his whole life
story before he runs this town
i do wonder if we'll see mace windu in
this show that would be crazy that would
be nuts
[Music]
oh
wow
do it off here do it i want my naked
boba fett survival story
go back to our rogue theory episode
wow cool
yes
i would like to have spent more time
there
damn how long was it down there for
showers yeah
oh we're gonna make a mint with these
boys
so i guess you really did love them like
amongst them
i really did live with them
i really loving the vibe of this
i would love it if this whole episode
just had no dialogue this feels even
more spaghetti western than mandalorian
[Music]
this music's [ __ ] sweet
come on do something
he's awake put him back to sleep
are all rodian's bounty hunters
oh sounds just like a puppy yeah he's
gonna be friended next
i love you boba
love you there goes the greatest
prisoner we ever took
is that the weapon that he uses yeah
yeah we're gonna get an origin for
everything except not because it's after
yeah
trial by combat
crazy
[Music]
so he probably fights like super brutal
from learning from that he's gonna earn
their respect and learn their ways
my man
it's a great healing pud they're lined
up to pay respects i'll let them know
you're on your way so godfather like
[Music]
robbery is writing this episode feels
like it
bends he probably did
because yeah it's definitely got some of
that energy in that
almost grindhousey
fringe mark chase mayor of moss espa and
its surrounding plateau is that matt
barry's voice major domo actually
need your domo
so you bring no tribute
the mayor's heart felt welcome
and regrets that he's been drawn away by
pressing matters milady
[Laughter]
he'd have fed you to his menagerie
apologies
apologies tell the mayor i'm here now
he knows tell the mayor to get his ass
over here perhaps another time next
actually there is one other matter if i
may oh my god dude
the matter of tribute
i'm confused
he wants you to pay him
[Laughter]
i'm the crime lord he's supposed to pay
me
shall i kill him
he works for the man
kick him in the pit lord vet offers the
gift of your leave unmolested apologies
and appreciation
the mayor may take it differently but i
shall indeed convey your sentiment
this is spot
they were captured alive as a tribute to
you lord fat
their tortured squeals will send a
piercing message to all potential
challengers to your throne keep them
alive
would you be loyal to me if i were to
spare you
this is a bad idea
[Music]
that's crazy city's built in like a pit
what the hell
or a canyon
if you're on tattooing you got it you
gotta have them it's the flamenco remix
looks like business is good
business is uh booming
i'm here to talk business
then business it is would you like your
gamorian's host down and fed while we
are sequestered
no no it's fine this won't take long we
can do it right here
making the long journey to visit our
establishment it is our little slice
paradise and you are always welcome
as it is yours now
[Music]
hey clean those really fast check the
helmets
oh nice
jabba rarely left us chambers jabba
ruled with fear i intend to rule with
respect respect
jabba also wasn't the most mobile
creature
fear is a sure event
oh wow
no no
oh no
is this the mayor's tribute
make an example out of them
[Music]
yeah my boys knew you wouldn't give up
or turn
[Music]
[Music]
come on you can handle it man
wow
it's so bad
singing birds
oh my god i love a good parkour rooftop
chase yeah
nice
[Music]
that's pretty cool yeah
it's more like the fennec we saw in bad
batch yeah
let's go back to your flashbacks we're
going to be visiting this pot a lot
during the series
your flashbacks play in linear order
picked up every time
interesting film grain effect to choose
and overexpose it
no hard feelings mate
[Laughter]
this would go a lot faster if you guys
helped you know damn my guy's good the
gabe's rigged
i would like a drink
what are you doing
say what that thing's gonna be alive
that is terrifying
guru
oh
no no no
oh
oh buddy
no
wow
[Music]
the monsters brawl with him
[Applause]
oh
super creepy cool design cool like
functional design
come on buddy
no you can see it like really tugging on
the neck
great detail
[Music]
are you a god
keep ticking for water
wow look isaac killed it actually this
scene is kind of like when leia choked
choppa
earn their respect
[Music]
you guys are going to tell me what the
name of that creature is
[Music]
[Music]
i was rob rodriguez yeah i felt like him
john favreau wrote this one cool
george lucas made star wars so what do
you know oh no way
[Laughter]
was that shot in the
that wasn't in the episode that shot no
it smells like original artwork that did
not end up going with
same creature clancy brown played in the
mandalorian hmm
yeah even this looks so different
that's so cool
look at they got the more remains than
this yeah yeah
what damners do they want him shirtless
they ever wanted him in a wine cloth
yeah where's that version it seems like
when they tell a more epic retelling of
what would yeah if we watch how it
really went down and this is the
heightened warriors version yeah
cool sweet dig sweet dicks let's talk
about it all right gang we got ourselves
the first episode of book of boba fett
some
fun stuff i like the real spaghetti
western vibe to it i feel like it's
really quadrupled down it felt very rob
rodriguez in terms of the pacing of it
like i'm a big fan of his films you know
i even watched like all the from dustil
dawn series as well which he directed
many episodes for and
of course like the movie from dusseldon
his you know the figuring the name of
the del mariachi trilogy yeah yeah
and so i really felt a lot of his
flourishes and pacing to it which in
some ways i i have perhaps a little bit
of criticism towards but for the most
part because of my love for this film
style of filmmaking um i quite enjoyed
it he even directed uh was it the fourth
episode of last season i forget which
episode it was the one
yeah yeah the one where they showed boba
going all tuscan raiders
yeah yeah exactly um so
i did i quite i quite enjoyed this one a
lot there's some things that i felt
could have had a little bit more of an
impact or a punch or wish they'd relish
in a little bit more but i'll reserve
some of that uh for now because uh you
know for a first episode it's solid so
so it's a solid start like there's no
i'm not complaining about that like for
a start it's really solid yeah yeah and
it's i mean i i think it's really fun
in that you have you know obviously
we're playing off of we're spinning out
of the mandalorian and obviously there
are many similarities in the demeanor
and the representation of danjarin
versus boba fett uh but i just love the
presence of him and fennec shand and
watching their little operation at the
very beginning stages and you know like
going into this show part of you thinks
well it's coming out of the mandalorians
so i imagine it'll have some of those
flourishes but what's the tone gonna be
and uh and this started out in a very
sort of gradual way where it does have
that mando quality where it's not like
we're moving the plot ahead a million
paces at a time you know it is very sort
of fixed and it has a lot of breath and
air and it's very experiential
and uh you know i can imagine that
detractors of the mandalorian might have
similar gripes about how this at least
first episode is paced but i really like
that and i really like like you said it
early on in the episode how they're you
know intensifying that western serial
vibe which is very rodriguez yeah
absolutely and borrowing so many classic
archetypal shots and stuff like that
always checking back in with the
multiple suns and the sort of heat
beating down yeah and i really like like
it feels like a spaghetti western with
the way they realize boba especially in
the flashbacks
because
he's he's got that interesting edge of
his personality where he feels like a
very relatable human within the star
wars world you know like like a little
that bit of that han solo touch
of that kind of cowboy who you know will
like complain and kind of be the
audience cipher of like what's this guy
talking about what's he like like you
would kind of think bobo would know
him more than he would sometimes be like
i don't know what the hell this person's
talking to yeah what's going on but he's
kind of just interpreting it in the way
like a very human portrayal um
which uh i appreciated the the the
revisioning of that for him here because
it makes him feel much more of a human
lead you can get on board with and
connect to you know it's like it's like
you have the star wars live actions with
and each trilogy installment of the
episodes has its own separate vibe and
flare then you got like the mandalorian
which has his own separate vibe and
flared all obviously all interconnected
and then this does stand out and feel
different although i would say what i
thought was a little bit weird to me is
that
and i don't know if you feel this way is
i i i i always felt like mandalorian it
felt like
sit like felt very cinematic
and
like short films in in a way like it it
didn't quite feel like a movie but it
felt more like a movie than a show in so
many ways this actually felt like a tv
show to me you know what i mean like i
thought this one felt like tv
with a great budget and some great
looking effects and visuals and whatnot
but there was and i think that's where
some of the rodriguez pacing kind of
comes in which is interesting it mainly
comes from film
but
but some of the way like how uh some
things kind of went by a little bit
quicker and the way it shot like the
action i actually expected a tad bit
more from it's only the first episode
but especially after the episode where
he debuted his ask hickory in
mandalorian i was expecting a little bit
more from some of the action again i'm
fully aware
first episode i'm sure there's gonna be
some cooler action scenes to come
um
but
yeah it was like there was there was
something about it because of the way it
was paced at
times where i should i felt like i
should have felt some real tension i
wasn't
yeah i i think i can share that with you
especially on sort of the pacing end of
the spectrum and certain of the
displacement of the events like the way
they do the flashbacks in the pod
certainly feels like the outset of a tv
show where we have to catch people up on
this guy's back where has he been what
happened after he got swallowed by the
sarlacc well i would have liked to be in
the sarlacc i would have loved a
complete episode dedicated yeah yeah it
would have been like very meditative and
quiet but but that's i was like more
into the
emotionally here's the thing the present
day storyline present day of him was
interesting as the mob part right yeah
but emotionally i was more hooked into
flashback stuff yeah and they're both
very simple in terms of the action
that's actually presented to you but and
i actually semi-meant this
early on in the episode it's like you
have so much that is done without
dialogue that is all based on body
language it's you know they're language
barriers that's great and so
i
yeah just going from my own personal
taste i'm like i would love to spend
more time in that realm because i think
tim warren morrison has a great physical
presence and as much as i like him and
fennic shan together when you get to the
present and you're dealing with you know
all the different uh emissaries of the
different uh powers that be around uh
tattooing like they're all showing up
all that stuff is cool but it's a lot
more straightforward and there's less
mystique because it is just kind of
linearly coming out of what we saw at
the end of
uh mandalorian season two and so yeah it
sure happened short as [ __ ] yeah sure
sure feels short that's what they think
too yeah and i don't know what's coming
you know like it's just the beginning so
obviously you give it a chance but yeah
it's like if i had my ideal episode it
would have been more of the kind of
thing where we spend the grand majority
of it in that time gap of okay what
happened to boba fett between the events
of him getting swallowed up by the
sarlacc and all the way to being found
uh by dinjarin like what happened there
and then end the episode back on the
throne with them taking over and then go
out like this didn't feel like place
setting in a way here's some necessary
backstory because a fans longtime fans
want to know and b new fans gotta get
endeared to this guy luckily since he's
been a slight character in the past it
lends itself to its inclusion here
but yeah it is i think the sarlacc pit
is a big one where i'm like
that's been the question
for so long and i felt like you just
went by so quick you know well yeah he
gets swallowed and i mean little oxygen
flip flame i'm sure yeah
it's like a couple minutes long yeah you
got swallowed and not to debate the the
physiology of magical made-up sci-fi
but at the same time you're like stomach
acids anybody like yeah you know and
there's another there's like a
stormtrooper that's also been swallowed
up in there what else has been swallowed
up in there he like jacks in his a
little air too like it's that moment of
survivalism that makes you go wow i want
to watch more of this and also it's
clearly a practical if assisted by cg
like a practical gut they've got him in
and that's another place that is well at
home in star wars but also we haven't
just been up close and personal inside
you know the belly of the beast well i
like the i like that what they're doing
with the tuscan raider side because the
main theory has been maybe he's been
living amongst the tuscan raiders and i
like how he wasn't just accepted in
there that he really was a prisoner who
they did kind of put through some
punishment yeah and then you see how he
earns his way to gaining the respect
with uh giving the water i i really like
all that oh that's that's what i mean
all the flashback stuff is like my
favorite stuff
of of like the tortured cowboy there is
a bit of like
i don't know a comparison though kind of
like last samurai dances with wolves who
were you know like the the the he's a
stranger
yeah stranger to strange lad he's kind
of kept as a prisoner at first but then
eventually he becomes indoctrinated into
the culture yeah like first one of
proves himself and then is welcome
accepted but only after some kind of
trial and speaking to the action like i
thought that scene with
again tell us what that creature is
called that goro slash centaur slash
lizard spy kids too which is a rodriguez
directed film there's like a spider
thingy yeah i don't know a spider i
don't know what it is it's an offshoot
of a thumb thumb i can almost imagine it
ah here's a photo for you guys yeah one
photo of this video but yeah uh i don't
know what it was but it's kind of look
like that too yeah yeah and that
sequence was was great and i i really
liked the parkour scene like i thought
that was cool and i gotta give it that
yeah yeah of course seems awesome in the
action i think the one thing i expected
a bit more i don't know i guess punch
out of uh was when they're all being
cornered by the guys uh i assume sent by
the mayor who were you know tasing them
and all that stuff like that felt a
little bit like even though i know the
point is to corral them and round them
up it still felt a little bit like
okay we got stunt guys kind of all
waiting for their their turn i can sort
of feel the choreography more than the
chaos in that moment but there's soon to
be a lack of build in the present day
storyline like i i felt like this could
have been an hour-long episode of the
ninja first one because emotionally i'm
not really feeling the tension or
suspense of the fight and really it's
not even about choreography at that
point it's mainly about like
this is all interesting
here but i'm just watching i'm feeling
like i'm not really feeling much yeah
like even there's some cool like i love
when he blows that one guy up yeah
that's a really cool moment
but yeah it's it i would probably give
this like a seven point five eight out
of ten you know that's pretty still high
rating um so that's a solid good
certified fresh yeah yeah uh c plus
yeah i would say i would say that this
is still pretty it's still pretty cool
and i like it and i'm definitely hooked
into it because tomorrow morrison's
awesome
definitely lost weight between
mandalorians yeah i feel like i gotta
get fit
my own show now yeah it's fine
if i'm gonna wear it i mean the suit too
looks amazing here yeah and i like
fennek a lot um it's me not when you
know she's the bomb but yeah having
fennec
involved in in the mix uh especially
what her her action reminds us reminds
me more of what we saw or do in bad
batch
uh which is really cool to behold
um but yeah you know it's like of course
i love world building and of course i
love seeing all that especially when the
like the parkour chase is awesome as
you're seeing more of the detail of the
buildings and tattooing and it feels
more lived-in
yeah so i really like that because of
that factor uh but you know i'm still
going to judge
an episode of star wars based off of the
storytelling
and
not just go cool more info
so yeah i liked it but i do think some
of the pacing was a little bit weird
with the present day stuff where i
didn't really feel much but the
all the flashback stuff i thought was
like oh i'd be fine if you just kept it
there like he's asleep go there cool
because i do laugh at like linear flash
back when yeah like that like i go to
sleep and i'm playing my offense the
exact order yes my subconscious just
needs to work through all this once
until it catches up to this timeline
got that moment no need to revisit
anything before yeah yeah and the
gamoreans didn't betray them oh man now
gamorans are loyal yeah
i know so much about gamoreans
we should get a couple
they did have that one character for the
clone wars reference too i thought was
really cool anyway guys
uh yeah what did you think about this
episode though uh did you love it is it
everything you guys wanted it to be
leave your thoughts down below all we
can do is keep it honest subscribe click
that bell hit that like button we should
also probably shout out some patrons
alex beware you've been for risky mr
crispy with elispe chris tuskin busting
star wars cliff robert rodriguez
directed this stacks to crook
always reading up from a book of boba
fett jaren warner you could just be a
star wars kid that's a star wars name
i'd like to sail with gail ferguson
craig nick x
x x
for sucks
rosalie taylor
sheridan this could have been better i'm
so sorry
paddington bear in the garage christy
elliott no chris chris hardwick hi
chris brown oh wow chris lawson phil
eider the spider
william
bryant cousy cousy lucy goosey
i hope that's somewhat relevant to you
ericans39
more like 60.
m-a-d-asmr
audio
senorita shakuita washington
what's up girl esperance per chance to
asdam dream
shakespeare christian man
manly ricas logan lerman lance burton
hey
you guys rock we love all of you
individually and as a group happy new
year happy 2021 and two and thanks for
helping us make this year a successful
one a good ass year
rock on
tonight
[Music]